فربما لم تتخيل ابدا انك قد تجني مالا
وانت تشاهد افلاما على منصه نتفليكس وانت
في المنزل ايضا تستطيع جني المال من خلال
ارسال مجموعه من البريد الالكتروني او
اجراء بعض الاتصالات مثل هذه الوظائف
السهله نوعا ما يبحث عنها الكثيرون لتحسين
دخلهم الشهري حيث يوفر نظام العمل عن بعد
الكثير من النفقات صحيفه ديلي ميل
بريطانيه كشفت عن تقريرا لشركه الاتصالات
يمكن ان تساعد في كسب نقود اضافيه
سنتابعها في الشرح التالي
جاء برنامج نتفليكس تاجر في مقدمه الوظائف
الجانبيه التي ازدهرت في عام 2022 والتي
يتوقع ان تنمو بنسبه
5400 في المئه هذا العام بكل بساطه تشاهد
محتوى المنصه ثم تقسمها حسب النوع للتسهيل
على المستخدمين ويمكن ان تجني منها 20
جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه الوظيفه
الثانيه المساعد الافتراضي توقعات بزياده
عمليات البحث عن هذه الوظيفه بنسبه
137% خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله يقوم
صاحبها بالرد على رسائل البريد الالكتروني
وتحديد المواعيد ويمكن الربح منها 30 الى
60 جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه الوظيفه
الثالثه هي النسخ الصوتي زاد البحث عن هذه
الوظيفه بنسبه 39% خلال العام الماضي
تعتمد على تحويل الصوت او الفيديو الى نص
مكتوب تحقق يصل الى 22 جنيها استرلينيا في
الساعه اما الوظيفه الرابعه هي مجموعه
التركيز على الانترنت تقضي بالمشاركه الى
جانب عدد محدود من الاشخاص في عمليه
الاستطلاع الاراء وتستخدم عاده هذه
الوظيفه بل تستخدم في ابحاث السوق
والانتخابات مثلا وتحقق ما يصل الى 25
جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه تتعلق الوظيفه
الخامسه بموقعي يوتيوب وتيك توك يتم من
خلالها الدفع لك مقابل مشاهده مقاطع فيديو
طويله على يوتيوب ثم اختصارها بمقاطع
صغيره وتحميلها على تيك توك يمكن ان
يتراوح الراتب ما بين الفي الى 5000 جنيه
استرليني شهريا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياضيات
يسعد صباحك اليوم ودوم اهلا بك معانا
دائما صباح العربي
اهلا وسهلا وشكرا على الموضوع الرائع شكرا
لفريق الاعداد على اختيار هذا الوضع اللي
حينقل متابعات قناه العربيه الى مستوى اخر
تماما لو طبقوها
يعني وظائف جانبيه من المنزل ازدهرت العام
الماضي ما السر في نجاحها
يعني تصرفات العملاء تغيرت الان الناس
بدات تتابع على جوالاتها اكثر مما تابعه
على التلفزيون كيف ممكن بدل ما نشكي كيف
ممكن نستفيد عنوان هذا البحث اسمه سهل علي
متابعتك لانه الاكثر مشاهده هو الاكثر
نجاحا والاكثر انتشارا واكثر مالا خلينا
ناخذهم خمس وظائف التاجر يعني ايش حق
النتفليكس تاجر انا بتسهل علي متابعه
الاشياء اللي ابغى اشوفها ابغى اشوف ابغى
اشوف دراما ابغى اشوف تحقيقات ابغى اشوف
دوكيمنتي ساعدوني انت لما تشوف هذه فين
تحطها في اي
كاتيغوريز هذه بيسهل علي المتابعه نيجي
للي بعدها الفرش والاسس او المساعد
الافتراضي انا انسان صانع محتوى وقت اجلس
ارد على العملاء ما عندي وقت اجلس احيانا
اعطي مواعيد
بكره الموعد الان بعد شويه يروح علي
موعد وهذا يسموها يعني انا ابغى ارد عشان
الناس يحسوا انهم متفاعلين معايا فاجمل
شيء انك تخصص لك واحد انت تفرقك المحتوى
ونخلي شخص موظف جالس يرد على الناس علموا
ايش يقولوا ايش الكلمات اللي يقولها نجي
للي بعدها برضو تتكلم عن الكونسيومر اللي
هي النسخه الصوتي ايش يعني نسخه صوتي يعني
انا الان مثلا هذا اللقاء لو طلع هذا
المقطع على على اليوتيوب 30% من الناس ما
يقارب ثلث المتابعين جالسين يتفرجوا بدون
ما يشغلوا الصوت زي نادين في الفواصل مثلا
تطالع في السوشيال ميديا ما تقدر تحط
الصوت فبتتابع فلو كان المحتوى مكتوب
هيصير مشاهدتها اكثر عجبها الموضوع والناس
صار تركيزها اقل فالمحتوى المكتوب نصا على
المحتوى المرئي يساعد في انتجاره اكثر من
الثلث 30% اللي بعدها مجموعه التركيز
والفوكس جروب قاعدتها او عنوانها اسمها لا
تفترض نجاح شيء قبل ان تختبرها تسوي
مونتاج تسوي خدمه حمله سي حمله اعلانيه
وقلهم ايش رايكم في الحمله ايش رايكم
بالمنتج ايش رايكم في الخدمه شوف رده
فعلهم اللي على اساسها ت
غير
شيء وندفع فيه اموال واشياء طائله في
النهايه بنلاقي رده الفعل انه الناس رفضته
ما عجبهم عشان ما اعرف تاخد هذا الخطوه
المهمه كمجموعات التركيز الاخيره وانا
جالس اسرع ليش ابغى هذا المقطع لا يتجاوز
بالدقيقه الى دقيقه ونص ليش برضو مره
ثانيه الناس اول ما تفتح فيديو او مقطع
بيشوف مدته اذا مدته تجاوزت الدقيقه ون
بعدين احطه تاج احطه في اي طريقه
فالاقتباسات او استقطاع المحتوى يتابع
تغييرات الناس لفتره تركيزها الان احد
البودكاستات المشهوره في المملكه سووا
لقاء مع احد المختصين اللقاء ثلاث ساعات
لكن لما بدا يستقطعوا منه دقيقه الى دقيقه
ونصف في كل معلومه يحطوها دقيقه دقيقه
ونصف انشروها بتنشروها في الانستغرام على
وهذه المشاهدات اللي بالطول بكامل الشاشه
عليها مشاهدات اعلى الان وصلت مشاهدات
الفودكاست هذا 33 مليون مشاهده يعني
المملكه شافوه تخيلي دكتور خالد غطاس مثلا
احد المؤثرين نفس الفكره يطلع مقاطع
مستقطعه جنب معلومه كامله في دقيقه الى
دقيقه ونصف ضرب عدد متابعينه الى اكثر من
مليون تماما مثل الاجوبه على الهواء
مباشره يجب ان تكون سريعه ومقتضبه ولكن
الكلام شيق اللي عم بتقوله بس انا بدي
اسالك سؤال هل هذه الوظائف كفيله وكافيه
انه تكون بديله عن الوظائف في العمل
جميل في قاعده جميله اسمها لا تختبر عمق
النهر بكلف مو تاخذ لي شخص واحد وتبدا
تدخل منه دخل تروح تقول شغلي لا كمل الان
انت تقدر تكون مساعد افتراضي لاكثر من شخص
ترد على هذا وترد على هذا وترد على هذا
وترسل لي هذا ايميلات ومواعيد وترسل هذه
شغلتك جربها بعد الدوام وشوف الى ان يصل
دخلك من هذه الوظائف الجانبيه
بضيفي هنا اقول لك تعالي خذي اجازه من
وظيفتك تفرغي لهذا الموضوع انت كنت تداومي
ثمانيه ساعات بعدين تروحي تشتغلي الاضافي
الان خذي اجازه من دوامك ثمانيه ساعات
اجلسي تفرغي الوظائف الافتراضيه هذه وشوفي
كيف دخلها اذا انا دخلت 70% وانا لازلت
على وظيفتي
لو خيروك بين الوظائف الخمسه مين اي وحده
بتختار تعمل فيها من المنزل عمل جانبي
والله انا اللي ابحث عنه انه محتوايا ابغى
شخص يقتطع الاقتباسات ويسوي لي فيها
الاشياء كلها يحطها في يعني
ويكتب لي عليها النصوص ويقطع لي لقاءات في
دقيقه دقيقه ونص لكل واحده ويختبرها على
الناس اللي حوله ويشوف ايه اكثر وحده
عليها مشاهده تخيلي لو قناه العربيه الان
سوت هذه الفكره بالكامل بدل ما ينزلوا
الحلقات كامله كذا انتم ما شاء الله
يعني سباقه في انها يعني تقتطع من
المقابلات ومن الهاي وبدقيقه ولا تتجاوز
دقيقه وعم تحصل كثير من المشاهدات زي
دكتورك ما شاء الله
فيك انا سعدت وحاسس بالفخر فما بالك انت
كيف كان شعورك تسلم واحنا فخورين بمعرفتك
كمان شكرا لك من رياض طراد مستشار تطوير
الاعمال